there was a rumor going around which now
I take as a compliment they said that he
only wanted to be my boyfriend because
he knew one day I was going to be a big
star
but I didn't even know and my because I
always had a really low raspy voice my
Drama teacher would only
would only who I do hope is watching
would only hire me as like some old man
like I was always like the fisherman
with two lines where I'd be like hello
like welcome to my boat or like
something weird
and so yeah she she had it out for me
and so she yeah she made me like the old
hairy man and like every freaking play
that we had
um her son was one of the boyfriends
that I was cheating on so I know for you
who got the last laugh yeah I I got my
revenge but anyways so then no one
really knew that I was really gonna do
anything because she never really Let Me
Shine gotcha except
for one play I we all got to write like
our own monologue and I did a I wrote a
monologue about like Metamorphosis about
like evolving from a caterpillar into a
butterfly and I came dressed as the
butterfly and the whole thing and
everyone started crying because it was
like I think it was it was really it
wasn't really about the butterflies it
was about everyone that I could see and
I could see like the potential in my
class and like oh wow
I mean it wasn't on me but it was also
like I feel like that's a
I really
something that's really important to me
is helping other people find their
fullest potential also um but that's
something in my adult life that I've
also had to detach from slightly because
sometimes you can see something in
someone that they cannot understand
themselves and so it can be very
frustrating and so you have to
come from a place of love and support
but not in a place of look what I've
done if you fall it's like everyone's
going to find their own place at their
own time I just had the same
conversation it's so two weeks ago with
I swear to God I just had the same
conversation with Will Smith two weeks
ago and Will Smith was talking to me
about uh
giving advice and how he's now learned
that the way that he used to give advice
was coming from such a arrogant uh and
cocky perspective I try to avoid advice
he was saying like I yeah I basically
was giving advice to say here's how I've
done it and now you can do it too which
is ultimately saying you can do this and
then become me and when he said the
light bulb went off to me in that time
and I was like damn you know I'm guilty
of the same thing like we had a real
conversation
without expectations and knowing
that no one owes you anything
that's been something that has just
changed
the way that
I'm able to express my compassion I mean
I've lived like so many lives we really
all have you know like different stages
everyone lives in such these like you
know in these chapters and sometimes
when you look at someone
that you've been it can almost feel like
you're looking at someone that you don't
know at all my life is so
I cannot believe it's my own I truly
believe I'm one of the luckiest [ __ ]
people I'm sitting with you in a castle
drinking wine laughing everyone here is
so amazing for putting this together and
I get to talk about my life and like my
life is I cannot believe it's mine I
feel so lucky so I have a hard time
admitting that I maybe need help
balancing something because I'm
overwhelmed because I feel guilty about
being overwhelmed because how dare I for
a second
feel
you know I guess some sort of hurt or
fear because almost like I don't deserve
it but I also
have become much more
fluid and flexible and way less Concrete
in this in my sense of self and
I
don't really have a definite sense of
who I am
[Music]